former FBI director Jim Comey and Robert
Muller have a long history of working
together both our key players in the
investigation into President Trump and
Russia interference if it indeed
happened in the 2016 election but have
they been coordinating with each other
good question right
that's what tom Fitton wants answered
he's the president of Judicial Watch and
has to sue now to get that answer Tom
what are you after here
oh we're after everything but more
specifically we want to know about what
Muller and Comey were up to as it
relates to these memos we had already
sued for the Comey memos and the Justice
Department told us what mauler has them
in his file so you can't have them which
was a big lie in the sense that they
gave him the Congress but we want to
know at what Muller and Comey were up to
in that regard we already know that they
colluded on the testimony that Comey
gave last year that talked about the
memos and was an anti-trump tirade and
you know mr. Muller's investigation
would not be here but for that illegal
leaked by mr. Comey through his friend
to the New York Times a week that's now
under criminal investigation or one step
away from being under criminal
investigation
you know mr. Comey has a lot to worry
about mr. McIver's a lot to worry about
but Muller he wouldn't have an
investigation but for those two men he's
the one who's running a zombie
investigation because everything's
collapsing around him the memo show
there was no rush of collusion Trump did
nothing wrong and the one who did
something wrong was call me and Muller
isn't even targeting him so Tom you're
wondering if it wasn't just the cumbia
professor they got those memos dropped
off to him you're wondering if Comey
dropped those memos right up to Robert
MOA and they'd call me get the blessing
of Muller to go around and start talking
about the memos to Congress and using
them in his book we've also sued for the
FBI FBI and DOJ to figure out how it is
that combing was allowed to use this
material in his book it was either
private or classified or confidential
and he should have been able to use it
and Muller certainly had to have been
involved in blessing that operation you
know Donald Trump has a lot of enemies
and it's called me it's Muller it's the
deep state and the FBI and DOJ
and it's Angela cape and two of those
people are facing jail time you know the
irony just quickly Brian is that Comey
is in the same legal boat as Hillary
Clinton right now the mishandling
classified information is a significant
legal liability for him and it was for
her and you have to wonder whether he
exonerated her because he was doing the
same exact thing you know was so quick
Tom it was okay I'm fired
I wrote memos put him in the New York
Times
Robert Muller it happened so rapidly you
wonder how did that take place now a
year later forensic ly were going
through it and he did something illegal
to make it happen and you wonder how
many of those pieces were in place
before the trigger was pulled with the
memo dropped so it is going to be quite
intriguing
I just don't think these these
higher-ups and the intelligence
divisions in law enforcement ever
thought there'd be somebody pushing back
like Trump and others were on this they
usually get away with a lot of this at
the highest levels commis a bad actor
the DOJ FBI Muller need to come clean
about its communications and dealings
with him after he was fired all right
tom Fitton in the morning often doesn't
wear a tie but for Tucker Carlson show
he does that is respect evening wear
thanks have a great weekend